Leena Lipinski is one of the voters
behind the surge in popularity of
Poland's ruling party she's a devout
Catholic who fell on bad times ten years
ago when her husband's business went
bust here with one of her three children
for whom she gets a government allowance
of $125 a month each they say our family
because before we don't have money to
pay for a food not only for food for
clothes but now I I feel like a normal
people and with dignity whatever their
political belief an increasing number of
polls many like polina have been
attracted to the Law and Justice Party
policies but it's a divisive situation
this couple believe voting for
nationalism and right-wing policies is
wrong it's our future and we have to
decide think control of the lower house
gives the law and justice party a fresh
mandate to continue where it left off
with policies rooted in Catholic values
set against what the party sees as a
liberal order promoting minority
interests against the wishes of people
who have family lives
this is Poland's main opposition sharing
their leadership in defeat accusing the
victors of polarizing society turning
state media into a propaganda operation
and encouraging homophobia by making out
LGBT rights are an invasive foreign
influence it was not an even struggle
there were no rules in it we didn't have
a feeling that we're taking part in the
fair competition or that the opponent
was using honest methods at home in the
outskirts of Warsaw Paulina Lipinski
isn't perturbed by the political rift
she believes in the ruling party's
mantra pride in Poland traditional
family values
Andrew Simmons al Jazeera also